these are dangerous times
we need khan the world needs him
two of these classic monsters are going
head-to-head
that's really so exciting it is a
spectacle it's
unlike anything you've ever seen but the
beauty of this particular story is
the different storylines on every
character he needs our help
there must be some way to disorient
godzilla you can look at the film as
two separate stories that intersect
eventually team kong and team godzilla
each human story is following the
monster story as well we believe that
they have an ancient rivalry the myths
say that their ancestors fought each
other in a great war
team khan you have alexander skarsgard
kaylee hoddle and
rebecca hall they're there really to
support kong and his
fight with godzilla the stakes are high
and it's a very risky
operation but we have to go through with
it all right matt
down the rabbit hole on the other end of
the journey we have
team godzilla millie bobby brown brian
tyree henry and
jillian dennison they're basically on
this adventure to try
find out why godzilla is attacking
they're trying to put two and two
together to figure out
why is this going on they're an amazing
team they complement each other so well
to be a part of that team is great just
trying to figure out how to actually
understand godzilla rather than trying
to destroy him
we always saw the movie as being
separated between team godzilla and team
kong
and that was exciting to me doing this
movie team con or godzilla
i'm a kung guy i don't know i got a root
for kong
hard for me to choose but as a japanese
person
godzilla i like king kong because he's a
giant monkey
and monkey's cool 100 team car i'm not
picking sides
you don't really want to pick a side i
gotta pick a side team goes a little
fast
you